le monde des champignons est un monde
méconnu qui suscite de plus en plus
d'intérêt la preuve le mic au tourisme
est en plein essor depuis quelques
années à certains endroits on en a même
fait une priorité de développement
régional comme ici au kamouraska
c'est sûr qu'on est un peu tard à 16 ans
mais on devrait retrouver le steak avec
quelques autres partout il ya un
champignon le d'un lymphome
c'est quoi ça les écureuils qui font se
pourrait pour l'hiver oui ils y font
sécher comme ça dans la mousse comme ça
il y en a souvent le plein variété
d'objets de mutants jusque là cela le
pied de mouton ou ligue ne signera un
bon comestibles on en voit bien les
petits aiguillant ici ce caractère de
l'application nous sommes dans le
kamouraska où pascale malenfant se
consacre au développement du mic au
tourisme un secteur en progression au
québec avec une hausse de 30 % de
participants chaque année depuis trois
ans je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
une saison exceptionnelle en terme
d'engouement en termes de productivité
aussi dépendamment des régions du québec
mais tout spécialement cette année on a
senti que les gens souhaitaient ce
retour à la nature
le champignon a souvent été leur choix
de comme quelque chose de nouveau pour
eux ou de la ces mystérieux aussi les
champignons pour percer leur mystère
maryse et me tessier fait découvrir les
champignons forestiers dans les terres
de la pourvoirie des trois lacs
il existe près de 3000 espèces de
champignons au québec donc quelques
dizaines sont comestibles
on peut penser entre autres
à la chapelle au bol et
des épis des togolais c'est pour aussi à
l'art millavois entre eux aux
champignons omar en début de saison on
peut trouvé la mort et y aussi
championnat marié particulier il subit
une métamorphose en fait parce qu'on
parle au départ d'un champignon très peu
intéressants la russule à pied co et
elle se fait effectué par un autre
champignon et pour miss ice et puis ça
devient la dermatose des rues seul qui
est un commerce il paraît intéressant
puis aussi distinctes de l'amérique mais
certains sont toxiques voire mortels
la seule façon de distinguer les bons
des mauvais champignons c'est
d'apprendre à les reconnaître
en plus de la couleur quelques règles
s'appliquent l'anatomie des champignons
il faut y en avoir de multiples des fois
on a des bonnes des fois on a donné tout
est lancé
la forme typique du champignon avec le
pied et le chapeau le death ou de
chapeaux toujours très intéressant de
regarder ici on voit bien les lamelles
sur les pieds on peut trouver
différentes d'identification parfois on
peut trouver un pied plus globuleux avec
une volvo aussi comme ça de jupettes qui
a toujours les pieds des fois c'est plus
un anneau qui va entourer le roussi pour
identifier chapillon une bonne chose
aussi c'est de regarder le milieu dans
lequel on est parce que souvent il ya
beaucoup de champignons qui vivent en
symbiose avec les arbres en plus on peut
regarder le sol si la mousse ou non
l'humidité une seule voix aussi donné
des indications
c'est en combinant ces différents
éléments qu'on s'assure d'une bonne
identification
le champignon qu'on voit sur les parts à
forestier c'est c'est le corps
reproducteurs du champignon qui est en
réalité partout dans le seul le
champignon cherche à se reproduire et à
disséminer ces sports
ça c'est une vis de look est au stade où
elle peut justement dégager ces sports
le petit nuage
ça fait c'est ça ce port est justement
qui va permettre de créer dans ce moment
c'est de créer d'autres champignons trop
beau il m'a dit oui et ce très bel canto
de google oui mais aussi ceux des
textures qui sont en plus
ben c'est pas dans notre autre dans
notre culture tient ses sorties les
asiatiques sont plus habitués à manger
finalement le conseil de pascal et de
maryse et d'apprivoiser le monde des
champignons un champignon à la fois
[Musique]